[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
édition spéciale noël du grand jt des
territoires sur vos chaînes locales et
régionales et sur tv5 monde avec la
participation de nos confrères de la
presse quotidienne régionale
c'est la magie de noël et nous allons
nous plonger dans cette magie avec un
rendez-vous à l'homme dans la vallée du
gier
chez françois colombes et l'ambiance est
magique chaque mois de décembre depuis
vingt ans des milliers de lumières
rempli son jardin et la façade de sa
maison
les voisins en prennent plein les yeux
plein les mirettes comme on dit dans nos
régions et les visiteurs viennent
parfois de très loin
cécilia ercis la elisa moulin pour la
chaîne t elle cette télé loire 7 sur
place regarder sa récompense
françois que l'on bella trouve dans le
regard émerveillé des enfants magie à
travers un parcours les visiteurs
peuvent découvrir le travail de françois
colombet des kilomètres de guirlandes
des milliers dans pool le spectacle est
fascinant et chacun est différent père
émerveillé d'année en année c'est de
plus en plus beau et puis voilà ça et
puis en ce moment en plus je crois que
on a besoin de tout ça toutes ces
lumières nous enchante
c'est très joli comme toutes les années
c'est pour ça qu'on revient toutes les
années c'est vraiment très très beau moi
j'aime bien tout ce qui est la lumière
en vente libre il allège coup ça fait
très joli mais difficile de trouver
l'artiste pour le féliciter
françois colombet est un homme discret
qui observent de loin les sourires de
ses visiteurs c'est une passion passion
c'était là j'aime tellement faire
plaisir en verve on a des gens qui
viennent de l'autre bout du département
pour voir votre maison oui les joueurs
firminy je vous dirais même que l'année
passée d'année dernière c'est des jeunes
qui viennent dans leur famille on a eu
un conflit privé dans ma mairie françois
colombet se fournit chez ludovic
audouard spécialiste des décorations
lumineuses pour les municipalités et des
professionnels mais pour son ami il fait
une exception alors que peut avoir
françois colombet ne se renouvelle pas
tous les ans mais parfois la facture
peut grimper jusqu'à 2000 euros
un investissement qui le place presque
orange des animations officiel de la
commune
ça se sait très bien dans la vallée ils
ont circulé viennent voir avec plaisir
que cette décoration
passé ce sont les genres de l'animation
qui nous plaisent bien que les gens ont
envie de vivre de plus en plus le maire
de lormes pourrait bien donner un coup
de pouce à françois colombet pour les
prochaines éditions
une chose est sûre ici c'est un peu lui
le père noël nous nous rendons tout de
suite à albi dans le tarn où les
festivités battent leur plein
quinze chalets d'artisans locaux ont été
installés pour le marché de noël sur la
place du vigan
c'est l'un des seuls marchés maintenu
dans la région alors les albigeois bien
sûr en profite et sont heureux de se
retrouver comme a pu le constater les
équipes sur place devient occitanie
la magie de noël s'est emparé de la cité
épiscopale tarnaise
depuis quelques jours le traditionnel
marché de noël s'est installé sur la
place du vigan
malgré les restrictions sanitaires 15
chalets d'artisans locaux ont été
dressés pour le plus grand bonheur des
albigeois ouais ça fait du bien au moral
ça fait du bien ben ça fait esprit de
fête parce qu'il y aurait pas eu tout ça
serait pas pareil
et puis voilà je pense que ça va donner
quand même du baume au coeur aux gens
absolument c'est très important dans
cette période de confinement de de
pouvoir avoir un semblant de vie normale
c'est aussi un soulagement pour les
commerçants david et artisans couteliers
installé depuis vingt ans dans le tarn
c'est la première fois qu'il participe
au marché d'albi à cause de leurs
collègues
je n'ai pas fait part et aux montres ou
ailleurs et je suis très content parce
que j'ai bien travail
le coteau customisation marche très très
bien et qui dit festivités de noël dit
aussi illuminations et albi on ne fait
pas les choses à moitié
[Musique]
pour la troisième année consécutive un
mapping géant a été installé sur les
monuments emblématiques de la vie d' un
spectacle qui ravi petits et grands
bah c'était vraiment super allez les
images étaient vraiment bien ça trouble
un peu la vision c'était super bien
c'est impressionnant c'est très réussi
c'est très réussi et puis elle et tous
les tous les pays et les civilisations
représenté à ces c'est une bonne idée ça
fait voyager cia sait c'est une belle
représentation du patrimoine mondial une
mise en lumière du patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco dont albi fait partie depuis
dix ans la magie de noël se poursuivra
jusqu'au 4 janvier 2021 nous savons tous
ses courses de noël sont souvent un
tracas mais si vous cherchez bien vous
trouverez tout de même dans vos régions
quelques marchés de noël ouvert oublier
les marchés géant bien sûr place à des
places plus modestes aux mesures
sanitaires très strictes souvent
d'ailleurs
nous partons ce coup-ci à limoges qui
propose une sélection de produits
régionaux
regardez ce reportage de 7 à limoges nos
confrères sur place
à pied en voiture voire en navettes
électriques gratuites tous les moyens
sont bons pour rejoindre à la place de
la république
des artisans et producteurs du marché de
noël organisé par la chambre de métiers
la chambre d'agriculture avec l'aide du
département et de la ville de limerick
suis amusé partisane créatrice
donc je fabrique en faïence des objets
très coloré très ludique
c'est une sorte de sécurité un marché de
producteurs parce que on sait que ça
arrive pas de l'autre bout du monde dans
un conteneur s'est produit ici et s'est
vendu ici tout à fait puis aussi on met
une âme derrière la personne qui la
fabrique et on rencontre la personne on
peut expliquer comment on travaille par
la suite on peut venir visiter nos
ateliers etc
donc c'est c'est une chouette démarche
on a besoin de ça aussi d'autant plus en
ce moment
chez où le port du masque est bien
respectée par les exposants et les chats
l'on bouge tous les jours et on essaie
de ne pas trop côtoyé quand il ya du
monde
regardez ces aides les distances sémien
absolument un marché de tradition mais
aussi un marché d'innovation à
rectangulaire d'une façon jamais les
dimensions de ne prend effet 43 31
et puis tiens c'est quand même plus
sympa du film en plastique benz a bien
évidemment mais c'est super alors ça
franchement je connaissais pas
j'en avais jamais vu deux écologique
c'est réutilisables ces principes c'est
pour éviter les déchets c'est de la cire
d'abeille cure avec des tissus limoges
oblige les arts du feu sont bien
présents céramiste et mayer et
porcelainier tiennent leur place
les métiers de bouche et les producteurs
sont également présents on peut même
trouver de quoi se remonter le moral
la tisane de noël à l'est de saison elle
est si belle elle est dans le petit
qu'on ferait avec ses beaux pétales de
rose gris kaki offrant sport tas dans le
jardin en plein été tout l'effort de
traduction
beaucoup de foire d'automne qui ont été
annulés donc c'est vrai que c'était
important pour nous que le marché de
noël puisse avoir lieu pour rattraper le
manque à gagner de
de toutes ces annulations soit génois
miettes une iranienne
c'est particulier aussi mais j'ai trop
la praline et noix miel citron meringuée
voilà c'est ça c'est les gourmandes mais
après il ya des plus classiques comme
t'es pas le dépiste fleur de lin faire
d'orange et bon j'imagine que ça fait du
bien de sortir de l'atelier de voir du
monde tout à fait les restaurateurs
riverains de la place est encore fermé
font une percée sur leur terrasse sans
objectif de rentabilité parce que je
pense que c'est plus un investissement d
autre chose c'est bien pour le moral de
tous les clients qui sont là les équipes
ont besoin d'être motivés voilà qu'ils
sentent un peu à l'abandon
c'est un père noël un peu triste cette
année habitué à jouer les père noël dans
un grand centre commercial en chine
le bûcheron vosgien alain simoneau ne
pourra pas partir cette année en raison
évidemment de la crise du coronavirus
une première pour lui depuis 2014
un mal pour un bien il passera enfin les
fêtes de fin d'année en famille
les équipes de via vosges sont allés à
sa rencontre et son duché lui regarder
ne vous y trompez pas c'est bien mon
habit de travail quelle ainsi mona nous
a ouvert ses portes ce mercredi à
gérardmer depuis 2014 chaque hiver ce
vosgien se rend en chine dans la
province du sichuan à chengdu une petite
ville de 14 millions d'habitants où
durant les fêtes de fin d'année il joue
au père noël pour le plus grand plaisir
des clients d'un gigantesque complexe
hôtelier
mais cette fois point de santa claus
dans l' empire du milieu
la perspective de trois semaines de
quarantaine là-bas et le confinement qui
vient de se rajouter ont eu raison de
son voyage mais à quelque chose malheur
est bon pour cet ancien bûcheron
autant j'avais un sourire et chats
ordinaire que je suis parti la première
année avec un autant maintenant j'ai la
larme à l'oeil gauche là où chaque fois
je m'en vais quoi finalement
finalement je vais me retrouver avec mes
enfants et mes petits-enfants pour la
période de noël
à condition qu'on puisse se réunit
apparemment va falloir attendre un petit
peu et puis le travail dans les vosges
ne manquent pas à alain simoneau possède
quatre gîtes dans la perle des vosges de
au grand valtin avec quelques travaux à
faire et ce ne sont malheureusement pas
les locataires qui vont le gênait
martray c'est magique est en ce moment
même bien j'ai quand même un petit peu
fébrile et pour la neuvième fois
m -a dans l'année moi j'aimais touristes
qui viennent de partir le mérite et
touche tous les moutons magie devient se
vider et les comme en avoir encore une
bonne semaine à travailler là ne les
aurais pas elle à la visibilité
la cellule pour le moins venir quoi les
temps sont durs y compris pour le père
noël qui espère bien que ses gîtes se
rempliront pour les fêtes de fin d'année
allez faisons un voeu direction la haute
savoie maintenant où il n'y aura pas de
noël au hameau du père noël vous allez
le voir l'association du petit pays
pensez pouvoir ouvrir ses portes au 15
décembre dernier après une saison très
difficile
mais les annonces du premier ministre
jean castex et les mauvais chiffres
sanitaire l'ont contrainte à baisser le
rideau pour les fêtes un nouveau coup
dur pour cette association qui
d'ordinaire accueil temps de sourire
reportage sur place de nos confrères de
8 mont blanc il était prêt à rouvrir ses
portes le 15 décembre
et finalement il n'en est rien le hameau
du père noël est privé de ces fêtes de
noël cette année un nouveau coup dur
pour l'association du petit pays qui
contraint d'annuler toutes ces
manifestations
c'est dur c'est dur pour les bénévoles
c'est que pour les salariés c'est dur
pour tout le travail qui a été fait en
amont parce qu'on savait pas trop quand
on allait ouvrir on ne donne des dates
on savait que c'était sous des
conditions
il a fallu organiser on n'a rien
organisé on voulait ouvrir par heure
avec des contingents on a modifié les
comptages en plusieurs nuits donc ce qui
est difficile c'est de travailler
énormément avec aucune carte est et ne
pas savoir vraiment du tout en bas et de
travailler quelque part trois fois plus
que normal pour orient alors pour cette
année 2020 les enfants sages ne pourront
pas aller déposer leurs sucettes au
grenier des tototte ni se promener dans
les allées féerique du hameau envoyer
c'est d'habitude ici que les enfants
amènent de norton tous les pauses avec
le marchand de sable suivant la grandeur
de l'enfant préposé après le marchand de
sable dans la soirée ou dans la journée
quand il avait il les pose sur sympa et
on se rend compte le sapin il a vidé
chaque année le 1er janvier on voit
qu'il ya très peu de tonnes par rapport
à l'année même si cet été puisque cet
été on ne peut plus être ouverts non
plus donc il ya très peu de tout
alors que d'habitude à cette époque le
sapin
même qui croule qui s'écrase de tout ça
ça plaît énormément énormément aux
enfants et jagger tout en clamant we
will avait une totale tout entièrement
open avec son sarcophage méthodes de
l'homme invisible napoléon on a pu
récupérer vraiment des pottok de une qui
ferait beaucoup aux jeunes filles c'est
kim kardashian voilà sept touati ski on
a eu la chance de le récupérer la tête
haute
c'est tout un folklore qui s'éteint avec
la crise sanitaire la partie musée est
fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre
mais la boutique du père noël elle reste
ouverte les trois fois plus grand
puisque tout pour ceux qui connaissent
tout la crêperie qui fait quasiment 300
m² + 300 m² et toutes transformées en
boutiques berne noël qui est transformé
aussi en boutique médiévale et être
soumis aux peurs boutique par des
épouvantails c'est pas le hameau qu'ils
ont connue mais c'est vrai que c'est
important de se dire dire ils nous
soutiennent en venant ils peuvent
trouver des choses qu'ils trouveront pas
dans les autres magasins puis c'est une
manière avec leurs enfants de passer un
petit moment de voir les bâtiments de
voir un peu ce qui se passe un moindre
mal pour le petit pays qui reçoit près
de 170 mille visiteurs pas cette période
avec l'annulation des médiévales et la
fermeture du hameau en 2020
l'association essuie une perte de 2
millions d'euros
elle se dit prête à vendre une partie de
leurs décorations pour subvenir à ses
besoins
il ya des discussions avec les banques
la discussion avec les bénévoles il ya
des personnes qui m'ont proposé de
prêter d'argent à l'association qu on
leur rendra dans une année on va dans
tous les sens on va peut-être
certainement vendre des voitures on
regarde pour vendre partie du matériel
dans les boutiques on se pose la
question de vendre une partie de notre
décoration quelqu'un spécifique puisque
on va en chercher dans toute l'europe le
même un peu plus loin donc aussi est-ce
qu'on vende et des décorations que les
gens n'auraient pas pu acheter ailleurs
ce qu'ils sont vraiment très très unique
on se pose toutes les questions et pour
l'instant le hameau espère que le père
noël passera avec quelques jours de
retard le 7 janvier afin de lui
souhaiter le meilleur pour 2021
cette période de noël est également pour
beaucoup d'entre nous l'occasion de
faire des découvertes
regardez ce reportage c'est un véritable
trésor que nous allons vous présenter
maintenant un véritable trésor caché
le manoir de verdi nier à avesnes en
saosnois dans la sarthe
ces bâtiments qui tombait en ruines sont
restaurés par deux frères propriétaires
des lieux
récemment d'ailleurs le toit du manoir a
été reconstruit à l'identique vous allez
le voir il est d'une forme très rare un
dôme impérial
qui a valu au maître charpentier qui l'a
restitué d'être lauréat national du
concours ateliers d'art de france
un reportage d'hélène galiana sur place
pour vyas lmtv sarthe
[Musique]
le manoir de verdigny est niché au fond
d'un long chemin de terre encore protégé
par ses douves l'édifice trône ici
depuis plus de 500 ans
une des caractéristiques de cet ensemble
c'est un signe fortifiée avec une
architecture de philibert delorme
c'est donc un site très très intéressant
au point de vue culturel
[Musique]
car imaginer à l'époque ses parents pour
le vie que l'on pénétrait à l'intérieur
du site
et si l'on n'était pas invité c'étaient
les meurtrières qui se chargeait de
l'accueil
le site abandonné plusieurs décennies
est en travaux depuis bientôt 14 ans une
restauration longue mené par stéphane
leroux il a restauré à l'identique un
dôme impérial sur l'une des bêtises
c'est un dôme à l'impérial qui a existé
que l'on l'a restitué grâce est une une
photo d'un historien damien castel qui a
retrouvé ce document là bizarrement une
photo de 1890 sur lequel il y avait
encore ce dôme et de ce fait monsieur
gagnon ont décidé de restituer ce dôme
là un ouvrage qui a permis aux
charpentiers d'être récompensée pour son
travail il est le lauréat du concours
des ateliers d'art de france ça donne un
certain plaisir de participer à
l'entretien d'un monument historique
et puis de le remettre en état pour
qu'il reparte pour quelques centaines
d'années si les s'il est bien entretenu
il reste encore beaucoup de travail au
sens du manoir qui n'a peut-être pas
encore livré tous ses secrets
pour les curieux les propriétaires des
lieux organise des visites sur demande
[Musique]
je
un slogan vaut mieux souvent que toutes
les déclarations vos assiettes sont vos
emplois eh bien c'est ce slogan que
lance la filière agricole pour venir en
aide au secteur des producteurs durement
impactées par la fermeture des
restaurants vous le savez durant cette
crise sanitaire
alors pour écouler les stocks toutes les
astuces sont bonnes vous allez le voir
dans ce reportage dans une ferme de la
plaine des vosges à sous l'os sous
sainte et lov avec les équipes de
viavoice sur place regardez moi j'aime
le saumon fumé pilote bud escargots
huîtres crevettes dingue canard une
épaule de biche battre comme ça une
bonne viande aux faux rythme annuel
voici un petit échantillon des mets qui
seront servis sur nos tables en fin
d'année reste à connaître la provenance
les chambres d'agriculture et les
syndicats agricoles gia et fnsea insiste
sur l'importance du consommer français
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire et
économique
le message c'est celui là un peu dur on
va dire du patriotisme gastronomique
notre agriculture vosgienne bien que
extrêmement riche et extrêmement variés
n'a pas tous les produits qui pourront
servir à la table la table de noël
donc effectivement le message est on
consomme local on consomme français et
on n'oppose pas non plus circuits courts
et circuit un peu plus long nez dans un
appartement on a des industries
agroalimentaires qui sont présents qu'à
gros entreprises laitières qui font
travailler nos concitoyens le
département des vosges est leader
régional en termes d'industries
agroalimentaires employant 4 l'huile
salariés les 167 ferme du territoire
font travailler plus de 3000 personnes
ainsi nos assiettes sont nos emplois et
période compliquée où les réseaux de
distribution sont un peu modifié parce
qu'on pourrait dire tout le monde
continue à manger mais il ya plus de
restauration où pratiquement plus tout
ce qui est restaurant d'entreprise
beaucoup sont à l'arrêt et c'est donc
c'est important que
les consommateurs dans leurs gestes
citoyens d'achat fasse attention à soi
vigilants à acheter des produits de
l'industrie agroalimentaire française et
qui sont produits sur nos territoires
l'annulation des marchés de noël les
fêtes qui se feront en petit comité font
craindre une chute du chiffre d'affaires
ici au gaec de la grosse roche à sous
l'os sous sainte et loft près de
neufchâteau
les gérants ont compris l'importance de
diversifier leurs débouchés
depuis deux mois il organise visite à la
ferme et vente sur place de la
coopérative qui venaient nous chercher
nos clés pas qui vient toujours
forcément notre viande etc
et du coup de fer transformée pour le
vendre en direct au consommateur local
ont trouvé ça intéressant
la vente directe représente pour ce gars
est que moins de 2% du chiffre
d'affaires mais ce changement de réseau
de distribution tend à s'accentuer la
plateforme l'okapi qui regroupe les
producteurs vosgien le développement des
drive fermiers et plus largement celui
des réseaux de vente en circuits courts
en sont l'illustration
nous partons maintenant pour la corse
cela s'appelle la bourse aux jouets à
cali s'est tenue la première édition de
cette brocante enfantine et les équipes
devient telle est pas aisé était bien
sûr sur place aux côtés de nos charmants
bambins regardes et tu es très bien pesc
et comme ça ça permet de faire de
l'ordre dans ma chambre et qu'il y en a
marre ranger qu'est ce que tu as fait
comme à faire toi aujourd'hui et beige
et vendu des livres surtout des livres
et un télescope un microscope
une loi est ce que tu en as tu d'autres
j'ai acheté ces castes oreilles
c'est une très chouette initiative de
vendre les jouets deuxièmement des
livres on est tous dans le même bateau
les parents je pense aujourd'hui les
enfants ont beaucoup beaucoup de jouets
on a trop de choses et c'est bien de
vendre ce qu'ils on utilise pas que le
quelqu'un d'autre pourrait utiliser
que les choses continuent à vivre on a
bien vu qu'il ya des parents des grands
parents des enfants qui étaient
contentes de dénicher un petit livre ont
un petit jouet une peluche en jeu au
final nous on est content de se
débarrasser et eux sont ravis d'avoir un
petit jouet à 56 - euros ou 2 euros
bientôt ce noël je pense plusieurs
personnes ont retrouvé des petits
cadeaux pour cousin cousine et neveux
nièces petits-enfants c'est mignon
aujourd'hui c'est une bourse aux jouets
chose qui n'a jamais eu lieu auparavant
les gens vendent échanges entre des
enfants dans des échanges entre une
seconde vie des jouets c'est un
recyclage donc les gens achètent à petit
prix peuvent offrir et hélas tout à
l'heure il ya une dame qui a acheté
beaucoup de jouer je pense qu'elle va
faire plaisir à beaucoup de petits
enfants le but c'est de mettre au point
des rencontres intergénérationnelles
c'est un endroit qui est mis à
disposition des exposants gratuitement
par la mairie de calvi c'est une
initiative du ccas quelques commerces
font l'effort d'être ouvert donc voilà
ça redynamiser un petit peu le centre de
calvi c'est une première mais je pense
que ce sera renouvelé tous les ans pour
ceux d'entre vous qui aiment les visites
et les excursions et bien si vous vous
promeniez dans une ville avec toutes les
archives en poche
c'est ce que vous propose ce reportage
alors imaginez vous en bretagne dans la
ville de rennes et découvrez des images
d'archivés d'histoires inédites de la
commune grâce à une appli qui est avec
vous pour tout savoir et pour tout
comprendre
voici les détails avec nos confrères sur
place de thé vert à rennes archives en
poche c'est la nouvelle application qui
permet de découvrir reine à travers des
films amateurs le concept propose de
visionner des images inédites
directement sur son smartphone grâce à
la géolocalisation pour l'instant une
quinzaine d'archives/reuters sur
l'application
on attend qu'elle terrain ou alors c'est
le chemin de l'école en faisant ses
courses on se dit tiens il ya peut-être
quelque chose à découvrir par ici on
regarde bien peu d'intérêt juste à côté
et on redécouvre la petite houle a
grandi
la crue de la vilaine en 1966 la
libération de rennes en 1944 ces films
argentiques inédits sont issus des fonds
de la cinémathèque de bretagne
c'est une manière de rendre hommage
aussi à des hommes et des femmes
qui à leur manière avec les moyens du
bord ont capté des moments qui sont
entrés dans la postérité des moments
qu'ils ont tourné souvent innocemment
sans se dire qu'un jour ces images
seraient conservés documenté et
valoriser pour que le plus grand nombre
en 2020 puis sont emparés rennes sert de
ville pilote pour le lancement de
l'application si le concept trouve son
public
archives en poche pourrait être décliné
dans d'autres petites et grandes
communes bretonnes
voilà noël c'est aussi parfois le moment
de rêver un peu nous partons à lorient
pour un voyage long cours qui va vous
faire rêver la goélette scientifique
tara a largué les amarres et pendant
deux ans eh bien elle va voguer dans
l'atlantique sud pour étudier les fonds
marins afin de nous en dire un peu plus
sur notre passé mais aussi sur notre
futur un reportage des équipes de tébéo
sur place en bretagne
tara à nouveau en expédition depuis son
port d'attache de lorient la goélette
scientifique est partie pour un périple
de 70 kilomètres au programme un tour
complet des mers et littoraux d'amérique
du sud et une remontée le long des côtes
ouest de l'afrique
les 80 scientifiques qui se relaieront à
bord vont étudier en détail le
microbiome marin mais qu'est ce que ce
fameux microbiome on a l'habitude de
voir des gros organismes des animaux des
plantes
mais dans tous les écosystèmes que ce
soit le séant ou le désert ou n'importe
quoi il ya toute une toute une partie de
l'écosystème qu'on voit pas qui est
invisible qui est le microbiome c'est
surtout les organismes plus petits qui
est à peu près 1 mm donc ce sont
essentiellement des organismes
unicellulaires comme les virus et
bactéries les arcs et des cellules plus
complexes comme les nôtres mais à l'état
unicellulaires tous ces organismes sous
marins microscopiques produisent 50% de
l'oxygène sur terre leur étude précis
sur les différents lieux de la planète
va permettre de mesurer leur état de
santé et du coup celui du monde on va
comprendre en fait comment l'écosystème
océan peut résister ou s'effondrer par
rapport à des changements climatiques on
va comprendre jusqu'où on peut aller en
fait les barrières qu'on ne devrait pas
dépasser pour maintenir un océan en
bonne santé et une planète habitable
c'est passionnant par définition parce
que c'est le monde de l'invisible
surtout c'est de voir un peu quels
impacts vont avoir les réchauffements
quel impact à la pollution aux micro
plastiques notamment sur ceux microbiome
qui a un rôle sur internet après son
retour à lorient dans un an et demi deux
ans il faudra encore patienter pour
analyser les échantillons microscopique
récoltés et ans à voir donc beaucoup
plus sur l'état de notre planète
voilà merci de nous avoir suivis pour
cette édition spéciale noël de grands jt
des territoires
bonne fête de noël à tous et rendez vous
dans une prochaine édition sur vos
chaînes régionales et locales et sur tv5
monde
au revoir à tous
[Musique]